one interesting little side question
there
is what is the natural state of being
for us humans
you kind of implied education
has uh polluted our minds but like if i
because you're referring to jealousy the
einstein question the steve jobs
question
i wonder which way if we're left without
education we would naturally go
so there is no such thing as the natural
state in that sense
right this is this is the myth of of who
sows uh uh noble savage
and of john walls is behind the veil of
ignorance
well if you're ignorant you're ignorant
you there's
you can't make any decisions you're just
ignorant
you're there is no human
nature that determines how you will
relate to other people
you will relate to other people based on
the conclusions you come to about how to
relate to other people
you can relate to other people as values
to use your terminology from the
perspective of love
this other human being is a value to me
and i want to trade with them and trade
the beauty of traders it's win-win
i want to benefit and they're going to
benefit i don't want to screw them
i don't want them to screw me i want
this to be win-win
or you can deal with other people as
threats
as enemies much of human history we have
done that
and therefore as a zero-sum world what
they have
i want uh i'll i will take it i will use
force to take it i will use political
force to think i will use the force of
my arm to take it i will just take it
so um those are two options right and
and they will determine whether we live
in civilization or not
and they are determined by conclusions
people come to about the world and the
nature of reality and the nature of
morality and the nature of politics and
all these things
they are determined by philosophy and
this is why philosophy's so important
because some philosophy shapes it's
evolution doesn't do this it doesn't
just happen
ideas shape how we relate to other
people
and you say well little children do it
well little children don't have a
frontal cortex
why it's not relevant right what happens
with as you develop a frontal cortex as
you develop
the brain you learn ideas
and those ideas will shape how you
relate to other people and if you learn
good ideas you relate to other people in
a healthy productive
win-win and if you develop bad ideas
you will resent other people and you
will want their stuff
and the thing is that human progress
depends on
the win-win relationship it depends on
civilization depends on peace
it depends on allowing people going back
to what we talked about earlier allowing
people the freedom to think for
themselves
and anytime you try to interrupt that
you're causing damage so this
change in america is not some reversion
to a natural state
it's a shift in ideas we
we still live the better part of
american society and the world
still lives on the remnants of the
enlightenment
the enlightenment ideas uh the ideas
that brought about this scientific
revolution ideas that brought about the
creation of this country and it's the
same basic ideas that led to both of
those
and as those ideas
get more distant as those ideas are not
defended
as though these ideas disappear as
enlightenment goes away
we will become more violent more
resentful more tribal
more obnoxious more unpleasant
more primitive
you